salut je suis ravie aujourd'hui d'avoir
sur notre chaîne parce que vous lis
souvent que je vous aussi tard aux lots
de la carolo j je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez la chaîne de la carolo j moi
ce que j'aime bien sûr d'achêne c'est
que c'est un fourre tout c'est que vous
avez c'est le foutoir ça intéresse tout
le monde même les mecs là quoique non
moi je suis abonné depuis et aujourd'hui
du coup je propose une petite
mentalisation l'idée c'est qu'on va
faire quelque chose ensemble
le but c'est de faire vivre l'expérience
de bluffer en même temps de vous bluffez
aussi aller si je regarde le retour
juste pas de retour sur ma caméra du
coup ce n'est pas la france et là je me
concentre en fait vous avez
l'association qu'elle regarde votre
front depuis tout à l'heure mais non
elle regarde là là je regarde là je
regarde l'objectif
le freestyle tu sais dessinais je donne
si c'est vrai oui cool alors je demande
à un dessin trop compliqué je te
recommande de ne pas faire un zoom
là j'ai des tatouages tu en as is it
interrogés par un truc ouais ouais ça
descendait
ok mais si triste de val d une énorme tu
veux branca un petit calepin petits
petits gars de concert tu veux petit peu
trop gros feutre au fait c'est la pire
des sims donc donc tu vas faire ton
dessin à partir du moment où je te
dirais un peu avant que je sois bien
prêt je suis désolé je me colle un peu
du coup conclut je vais te demander
alors à temps oui on pourrait aussi
penser que je regarde le retour écran le
fait virer mince tombés d'accord je veux
juste retourner leur tour écran pour
vous ça change rien mais c'est pour pas
bien témoigne voilà c'est pour toi
puissiez croire que que je vois quoi que
ce soit ok on se met en place
tu vas mettre ton feutré oui à l'endroit
où tu vas commencer dès le ton dessin tu
vas faire un premier très commence à se
dessiner en fait tu vas le dessiner mais
lentement
le melon
ok vas-y tu continues tu as fini tu
l'avais fait un premier très d'accord
comment sera gérée pâtit ouais ouais
continue jeudi soir ouais bah va
jusqu'au bout de ton des sables en fait
je veux dire quelque chose cerveau ce
que je sais que j'ai dessiné je ne sais
pas ce que j'ai dessiné d'accord soit je
décide et très mal et je perçois un peu
mal et du coup ça ressemble à peu près
soit je suis tellement à côté que ça va
être tellement drôle et du gouvernement
d'avoir tomber ça et que je vais pas le
faire voir pour l'instant je le gardais
contrat juste le faire voir un peu vous
abonner qui regarde la vidéo voilà comme
ça on verra qui a pas de triche que je
change pas de dessin tu peux te répondre
c'est un rêve le foot parce que tu peux
nous faire voir ton temps des ce1-ce2
les as et une bouche si jolie ta bouche
alors écoute du coup ça va j'ai plutôt
satisfait de ce que j'ai fait sur que je
dessine très mal mais je sais ça quand
même pas mal et je vous jure qu'il n'a
pas mis leur tour vraiment et ce truc
est quand même c'est pas mal mais tu
comprends que je savais pas ce que
j'allais des cacahuètes peut-être une
kaka une pistache regardez le ba ba non
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère que
ça t'a plu oui franchement chapeau c'est
ça je pensais pas éclipser le grand
peintre s'est vraiment passé maintenant
ça peut être une bonne chose mais oui
mais tu entends que c'est une bouche
d'ailleurs méthyle boucher la conception
sauf que temps que j'avais pas vu ton
dessin je savais pas que c'était une
bouche si vous connaissez pas la chaîne
la carolo j je vous mets un lien ici et
je voulais un bien dans la description
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de lalique et et vous
pouvez également vous abonner à ma
chaîne à moi aussi si c'est pas déjà
fait en cliquant par là où par là parce
que le mental blog c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre qui fait
que peu de gens ont vu toutes les vidéos
c'est vrai rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
calao
et